why is everything chrome Haley Bieber is
officially on tick-tock and obviously
her first video features hubby Justin
why is everything chrome he's a good kid
is a good part and I love the pair looks
adorable in the vid Justin in comfy
street where Haley in her PJ's she's got
me wrapped around her finger pretty much
so you say googoo when she says Google
yeah see we're both each other's goo
Goo's it's good stuff Haley joining
tick-tock comes about two months after
Justin joined his first tic TOCs were
all about yummy yeah you got that
[Music]
i annoy Hayley when I constantly singing
around the house she likes it but then
there's a point where I think I don't
know I don't know what I feel like she
loves me a regardless of anything I do
but I don't thinking around the house is
not annoying Justin wouldn't you know
they'd pay for that yeah I have this
thing is chick in the game she's so
awesome the pair aren't the only celeb
using tik-tok to pass the time amid the
coronavirus quarantine who fell in love
first who's more annoying when they're
hungry
[Music]
but here's hoping into even more Halley
and Justin tick tocks why is everything
Chrome
[Music]
[Music]